well European Union interior ministers
are meeting in Luxembourg today to
discuss how to deal with migrants
arriving across the Mediterranean Sea
countries including Germany France Italy
and Malta have already agreed to accept
a share of migrants rescued at sea now
they want other EU states to join in a
new voluntary resettlement scheme
according to EU law asylum seekers must
register and stay in the country where
they first land and that has put
enormous pressure on Mediterranean
states so far this year
Spain has received more than twenty
thousand migrants Italy almost 8,000 and
Greece over forty thousand migrant
arrivals are down by 30 percent this
year but when boats do arrive Europe
often struggles to respond it's hoped
that today's meeting will deliver a
solution it was a moment that changed
the debate around migration to Europe 31
year old cat hole a Takata forced her
rescue ship carrying 40 migrants into
the harbor of Italy's Lampedusa Island
she was arrested for defying Italy's ban
on private rescue ships entering its
ports as it stands when an aid
organization rescues migrants in the
central Mediterranean EU countries are
forced to scramble to allocate the
arrivals among themselves both Italy and
Malta which lie close to the north
african coast say it's unfair that they
have to accept so many of those who come
to Europe's Shores at the end of
September interior ministers from Italy
Germany and France met in Malta to
discuss a way forward they agreed on a
mechanism to automatically distribute
the migrants who arrived by boat dealer
to the unlogical members the people who
come to shore must be distributed they
can do a security check at the point of
arrival through interviews but they
can't process all their asylum claims in
such a short time not if we want to
comply with the law that must be done in
other you countries as well now Germany
France Italy and Malta are hoping to
convince other EU member states to sign
up to the migrant resettlement scheme
GWS max Hoffman is in Luxembourg
covering that meeting for us max The
ministers are seeking agreement on how
to deal with migrants crossing the
Mediterranean tell us more
about what's on the table it is that
Maltese relocation mechanism which is
automatic which changes things because
before that it was not automatic and
they have to have to haggle over every
ship now the problem with this mechanism
is that so far only four countries have
agreed to participate in it
Germany Italy France and Malta and if
you do the math that gives Germany a
pretty large share of those refugees so
far about a quarter of those that are
rescued at sea so 25% it sounds like a
lot and hast a hole for the German
interior minister got a lot of criticism
because of that in turn and many but if
you look at the actual numbers it's not
that much the interior ministry is
operating with 225 refugees taken up by
Germany so far so it's no wonder that
all see Holger upon arrival here in
Luxembourg said that this discussion in
Germany was shameful given the very
small numbers the EU member states have
been deeply divided on migration policy
over the years what are the chances that
the ministers will actually reach a
consensus on what's being proposed today
you know you have to remember it's very
limited in scope what they're talking
about this this relocation mechanism
it's only for the central Mediterranean
route and it's only for those that are
rescued at sea so you would think that
it wouldn't be that hard to convince
other countries to participate in that
and that's exactly what hall C office of
the German Interior Minister is going to
try to do here today in Luxembourg but
it doesn't look good he didn't sound too
optimistic when he came here he managed
expectations we know that some countries
are ready to help for example Portugal
or the Baltic States just not right now
so we don't expect any concrete
agreement here today
tell us max why is just the central
Mediterranean the focus of EU efforts to
deal with migration right now and
there's far more pressure in the eastern
Mediterranean
because it was the one that caused the
most headache in the in the past months
really because as I mentioned my first
answer every ship that arrived there was
that they needed to negotiate where it
could go because with the old Italian
government they just wouldn't let those
ships disembark in Italy and Malta
didn't either so there was a lot of
phone calls over the weekends and they
were just kind of fed up with that and
said for that little number for that
reduced number of refugees we were
talking about we can have an automatic
mechanism but you're absolutely right
the Eastern European states like Greece
or Bulgaria or also Cyprus are dealing
with much larger numbers of refugees and
that's why the ministers of those
countries today here are complaining
that they're not in the focus of
attention and by the way it looks like
that's going to change with migration
numbers ramping up in that area max
thank you very much for filling us in
DWS max Hoffman there in Luxembourg